لكل منا حلم حاول تحقيقه بشهادته العلميه
فكلما ارتفع مستوى التحصيل العلمي يفترض
ان يزيد العائد المادي والاجتماعي ووفقا
لتقريرا من جامعه جورج تاون فان حاملي
درجه البكالوريا سيكسون 84% اكثر من
الحاصلين على شهاده دراسه الثانويه فقط
ومع ذلك فان 44% من جميع الباحثين عن
العمل من حملت الشهادات الجامعيه يندمون
على مجال دراستها وذلك لوجود اختلاف مذهلا
في الاجور بحسب مجالات الدراسه الصحافه
وعلم الاجتماع والاصالات والتعليم تصدرت
قائمه التخصصات الجامعيه الاكثر ندما
بينما شعر بالرضا اصحاب تخصص علم الاجرام
والهندسه باعتبارها من بين الاعلى اجوره
[موسيقى]
اليوم هل الندم في التخصص الجامعي لدى بعض
الاشخاص هو مرتبط بقصر النظر لما قد يخدم
مثلا هذا التخصص في المستقبل ام ماذا
هل ندمت انك درستي اعلام انا درست صحافه
واعلام لاكون مذيعه اخبار سياسيه وفي مكان
مرموق مثل العربيه وهذا ما حصل
هل انت طبعا عشان كذا بنقول انت حبي انت
هذا الشرف تكوني فيه ودرستي وكنتي فيه
مشكلتنا الكبيره جدا وهذه رساله لمعالي
وزير التعليم تنادين 50% من 40 الى 50% من
الناس اللي تخرج جمعيه يعمل في غير تخصصهم
الدراسي او ما يكونوا حابينه والاربعين في
المئه ولا 60% الباقيين اكثر من نصفهم ما
هو مبسوط هو بيشتغل بشهاده امهم مبسوط ليش
بيحصل الجاب هذا نبيل الان عندنا مبادره
جميله من وزاره التعليم انهم بيحددوا
مسارات الثانويه العامه في مسار علمي في
مسار ادبي في مسار مهني في مسار مثل
الجابر اللي صار لو يعني ولو
المبادره الجميله
سارت زي ما بصير في دول متقدمه جدا
التقييمات الشخصيه للطلاب والطالبات انا
بتوصلني رسائل
بيقولوا لي ابناءنا متوترين جدا مطلوب
منهم يختاروا تخصصين كيف يختاروا في
تقيمات علميه تقول لك ابنك عنده ذكاء من
هذا النوع ينفع يعني ينفع شفت الشابه هداك
اللي يقول لك انا مبسوطه مهنتي وما كنت
متخيل اللي انا وصلت فيه الان حد نقطه
جميله جدا
العادات المجتمعيه ورغبه الاهل بتفرض على
الانسان يعني وتوجه لا يرغب في حياته
للاسف هذه من اقصى واصعب الاشياء اللي
صايره في المجتمعنا اولا الاباء والامهات
الاب ما صار دكتور يبقى ابنه يصير دكتور
الامه صار
ت بنائس المهندس الحجر الثانيه الاصدقاء
يعني معظم اختيار التخصصات يا والدين يا
اصحابي داخلين الجامعه الفلانيين رايح
معاهم انت مين انت ايش تحب ايش اللي
يناسبك انت بصمه مختلفه عن اي احد في
الحياه الحاجه الثالثه المتاح يعني اللي
يجي يقول لك والله قدم ايش تبغى تطلب في
الجامعه
طيب هندسه همم فنون طب انا انسان يناسبني
طفل ما ينفع تقول لي ايش تخصصات ثانيه
بعدين تقول لي والله خلصت طيب يلا روح
حياتك عشان ما عندنا الادايه تدخل فيها
اروح ادور مكان ثاني
[موسيقى]